what is going on everybody and welcome
to part 2 of our Raspberry Pi tutorial
series in this part what we're going to
be talking about is setting up and
installing an operating system to a
Raspberry Pi there are quite a few
different ways to do this if you're
familiar with is OS and mounting images
and all that you can just mount to the
image to the SD card and then boot the
Raspberry Pi and you're all set but the
problem is that's most likely unfamiliar
to a lot of you at least it was to me
when I first got started with the
Raspberry Pi and actually the Raspberry
Pi was kind of my intro to a Linux based
operating system in general so a lot of
things kind of being thrown at you in a
really short period of time so it's
easier to start with their new out of
box software conveniently called noobs
so - that's the method that we're going
to use but you don't have to use that
method if you don't want it so go to
Raspberry Pi org which is a pretty good
website you can get a lot of good
information about the Raspberry Pi news
all that kind of stuff from here but
what we're going to do is head to
downloads and here you have two two main
choices so the main operating system
people uses raspbian but we can use
noobs to download and install raspbian
so if you go this method the main issues
you've got to get something that will
mount the image to the drive or the SD
card rather which adds kind of one extra
step to the whole procedure and it's
just a whole lot easier with noobs and
then should you screw something up or
you just want to start from scratch with
noobs it's a lot easier you hold shift
on reboot and reinstall an operating
system it's nice so since we're going to
use but you do also have a few others
you've got an Ambu tube version and by
the way all these are basically
specially made for the raspberry PI's
arm CPU and the architecture all that
basically just for what the seat of what
the Raspberry Pi has to offer you these
are operating systems made specifically
for that anyway what we're going to use
is noobs to start so go ahead and click
on that and I should take you here
noobs light will download quicker to
your computer but when you actually
install it on the Raspberry Pi it will
take
little longer whereas this one this is
the offline in network in Seoul so
actually the full operating system will
be there for you to install it so that's
the one that we're going to go ahead and
download or that's the one I'm going to
suggest you download you can do the lite
version too if you want I just suspect
that the Raspberry Pi well it does have
a LAN port we're just going to use the
Wi-Fi so it should be quicker on a wired
connection anyway but download whichever
one you want and if you want to wire up
your PI go go for it so go ahead and
click on the download zip that'll
download that and you should be good to
go I'm going to go ahead and diavik's
I've already downloaded it and extract
that but while you're waiting on the
download go ahead and pause the video
until the download is complete and
whenever you're done we'll continue on
so assuming that you've got it
downloaded you will want to extract it
already kind of did that step but if you
need to you can right click extract and
just extract here that should give you a
new directory and then inside that
directory is a bunch of content so we
want to put onto our SD card now before
we go and do that though we want to make
sure that we have a formatted SD card so
what you want to get is this SD card
formatter and then download whichever
version you need you can also like
really it's just windows that really
needs the SD card formatter on Mac you
can download this but it's not
absolutely essential and then on Linux
you can use gparted
and you're totally fine so I'm going to
go ahead and plug this in alright so
yeah mine is Drive L you want to
definitely make sure you got the right
Drive there because if you have like a
USB Drive plugged in that'll also be one
of your drives that you can format and
you don't want to do that most likely
but so make sure you get the right Drive
now what you're going to want to do
assuming you're using SD formatter but
pretty much everything is going to be
the same but basically you don't want to
quick you want to full and go ahead and
erase and then size adjustment go ahead
and turn that on so this should just
totally reformat your entire Drive so
we'll go ahead and hit OK and we'll hit
one that yes great now once that's done
we can go ahead and exit we won't need
this anymore and then we're going to
come over to the actual drive itself so
this is the drive L and then take the
nude stuff that you downloaded and take
basically all the contents there and
just copy them into that drive might
take us I suppose a second that's taken
a while I think it's only a gigabyte I
don't know why it's taken so long just a
lot of files I guess anyway go ahead and
do that and then whenever that's done
basically you can unplug the SD card and
we'll put it in the Raspberry Pi we hook
up the Raspberry Pi and we can start the
the actual installation process the
installation process kind of takes
awhile so it's kind of a pain in the
butt
so I suppose while we wait I'll point
out a few things on the Raspberry Pi it
chances are you're probably familiar
with them already but let's go ahead and
reference that one copying this over so
on the Raspberry Pi we've got a bunch of
different things here but obviously the
main things that I was pointing out
before you know you've got the GPIO pins
and just in case I forget in future
let's do this this is the way you
typically will orient the pins so the
the pins when you look at like a pin
diagram it will be the top right assume
you put the pins at the top right
this obviously is your Ethernet ports
these are your USB ports this is your
camera port for the official USB or the
official Raspberry Pi camera module not
a USB camera this is your HDMI that is
the video in unless I'm horribly
mistaken that's audio I've never
actually used the audio that's your
power trying to think here so if you for
some reason I have a few monitors that
are like new monitors they're not super
old or anything but they do not have
HDMI input so what you can do if that's
you because this requires HDMI is you
can actually get DVI to HDMI or HDMI to
DVI converters just like a little thing
so basically you run the HDMI cable into
that converter it converts HDMI DVI and
then
you could connect that to your actual
monitor if that's something you need
hopefully not so anyway those are just
like a quick run-through of the stuff on
the Raspberry Pi generally what you
probably want to do is connect
everything especially when we're doing
the GPIO s make sure you connect
everything before you connect power when
you connect power to the Raspberry Pi
that turns on the Raspberry Pi if you
shut down the Raspberry Pi leave it
connected to power it will stay shut
down and then turn it back on there is
no on/off switch you unplug power plug
it back in you're good to go okay my
files are copied over and now we're
ready to plug in the SD card to the
Raspberry Pi and we're ready to plug in
the Raspberry Pi booted up and get
started so let me go ahead and put this
in our Raspberry Pi so obviously the
actual you know pins to read the SD card
are on the bottom of the board so you
stick the SD card in underside like that
stick it in and you're good to go so now
I'm going to go ahead and do is pop over
here I've got the computer all set up
with it an extra keyboard from the 1970s
into a monitor and all that so I'm gonna
hook everything up over there so I will
see you all in a moment okay once you've
got everything plugged in I got the
keyboard mouse and the HDMI for the
monitor once you do that you're ready to
plug in the power to the Raspberry Pi
and again once you plug in that power
the Raspberry Pi should boot up and
we'll get to the actual nudes
installation screen and I'm actually not
sure where my mouse is but that's okay
you actually don't need your mouse for
this step we'll have to find it soon
though but you should wind up on this
screen I apologize for the recording of
the screen I promise I won't do that
this whole tutorial I just can't really
record just this screen I could use a
virtual machine or something and go
crazy but this is just for like five
seconds so I'm not going to worry about
it anyway go ahead and choose raspy and
I'll hit enter and then I to install and
enter yet again and you'll begin the
actual installation process for raspy
this will take movie 15 20 30 minutes so
I'm gonna go ahead and pause here and
then I'll continue once we are done here
all right so when the operating system
is done installing you should get a
little message says it's done you'll hit
enter and it will restart and you should
wind up with on the GUI desktop
something like that now in the past the
background used to be a raspberry I kind
of miss it you can change the background
if you want but we're not going to worry
about that for now now what we want to
do is actually update our raspberry pi
to all the latest and greatest things to
do that we need to connect to the
internet first now the raspberry pi 3
has Wi-Fi and Bluetooth built in which
is awesome but we obviously need to
connect so go ahead and connect to you
either your Wi-Fi network or connect an
ethernet port our Ethernet cable to the
port and then you can go for Wi-Fi you
can go up to the top right corner there
and where it says there's no connection
basically the up and down with the black
or the red X's click on that and choose
your Wi-Fi can you guess which one's
mine so anyway once you've done that
once you connect to the internet you are
ready to do the updates now in most
cases in a beautiful world you can just
do sudo apt-get update and hit enter
you'll run through that and then up
great now in the past that's always
worked flawlessly for me it's never been
an issue but for some reason as I was
trying to get through these updates it
was taking way too long so update
usually take maybe I don't know a minute
upgrade could take maybe 5-10 minutes
sometimes but this was taking infinite
time and then it was just disconnecting
so hopefully that won't be a problem for
you but if it is a problem for you let
me show you how to get around dealing
with that also we're going to remove the
wolfram engine it's sucking up like 700
megabytes of space which on our little
SD cards especially if you got an 8
gigabyte or even in 16 that's a good
percentage and we don't need it so we're
going to account for that so first of
all the first thing I'm going to do is
mute my sound and we're going to use
sudo nano death slash e TC slash camp
slash sources
sources.list for these commands I'm
going to explain we're going to get into
a little bit more depth about what's
going on here so if you're not familiar
with a Linux terminal and all that don't
worry we're going to talk about that but
first I just want to get us all kind of
updated in on the same page so go ahead
and and what this is going to do is edit
that file so with the enter and we're in
the file will off my screen but I'll
just bump it down here so there's what's
the contents of this file so and in fact
this one almost looks like it's been
changed it used to be I've actually
probably edited this one already so what
you'll want to do normally like if it
just says archived raspbian dot org
that's probably fine what it said before
was like it was like a mirror and for
whatever reason that mirror was not
doing well so if it doesn't say this
what you can do is go to that go to the
two lines it should just be two lines
and then go to the raspberry pi part 1
of this tutorial series so if you go to
Python programming net find the
raspberry pi tutorial you can just
search for it and in fact I'll just show
it real quick yep
type raspberry pi and here's this series
that we're doing right here click on
that big blank because the videos are
being recorded right now but scrolling
on down this will probably be the part
two actually but coming on down after
the installation here are the commands
and basically you're going to want to
copy this entire a little bit just copy
that move that over and over here on
these two lines do ctrl K K that just
deletes the whole line and then you can
just right-click in that paste in there
and then we're going to go ahead and
ctrl X to exit yes to save enter to just
keep that file name okay now once you've
done that what we can do is sudo apt-get
disk - upgrade
[Music]
we'll wait for that and then after that
we can update and upgrade and we should
have no more major issues but actually
probably after the update as we will try
to do both and I'll just pause because
we still will do the oka hi yes
stupid wolfram engine I can't wait to
get rid of this we probably should I
just purged it immediately
maybe I'll pause while we wait for
whatever reason this thing is so slow
[Music]
we'll try and purge it first let's see
if we can get away with purging it first
so instead what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to do sudo apt let's app -
get purged wolfram - engine that's
unfortunate that it didn't make a new
line but anyway enter 683 megabytes will
be removed heck yes let's do it
that's man bye you'll be missed actually
don't know what the Wolfram engine even
is to be honest raspberry pi + Wolfram
engine equals wasted speech yeah I still
don't know I I don't know what the
Wolfram engine is I'm not like trying to
figure out what is the Wolfram engine oh
no someone can post below there it goes
finally it's moving something's
happening I'll just pause for now
another one just like sit here in
silence so I'll pause go ahead and pause
the video and then whenever this is done
removing this bloatware we'll be ready
to continue of course as soon as I pause
it's done so okay once we've done that
lets go ahead and
sudo apt - get auto remove remove yes
this hopefully will go faster than that
did and then once this is all done we're
going to suit have to get update should
I've get upgrade and then we'll be done
in the next tutorial we'll start getting
into actual remotely accessing PI I
suppose I'll pause again and when this
is done well we'll pick it back up of
course as soon as I hit pause though
it's going to be done it took a few more
seconds okay sudo apt-get update and I
guess I'll pause on this one this one
should only take like maybe even a
minute maybe it's almost even done I
don't know and then after this we'll do
the upgrade the upgrade will probably
take a little longer it can take quite
like five minutes or something maybe
less I don't know anyway I'll pause and
continue when this is done okay sure
enough yes
actually I don't even know what it just
happened here did I I might have just
control seed out of that accidentally
let's make sure I didn't screw that one
out applause again make sure I've ran
tact correctly
okay then finally we're going to do a
sudo apt-get upgrade and this is the one
that will take a little longer it should
calculate some stuff you'll say yes or
no I'll say yes and the process will
begin this one I'm definitely in a pause
and just carry on to the next video once
this is done